I made it to the toilet
older people with smaller bladders it
would be wonderful if the toilets in
this building were a little closer Thank
You Jennifer Thank You Ronald god I'd
love to invite them to my funeral two
months ago we were in Rome Francine
Rosetta died it was the 6th of September
I had just finished a day's shooting of
trust for Danny Boyle and Simon Beaufoy
and we were sitting on the little
balcony of our hotel rooms it was so
narrow that if I put the soles of my
feet on the railings my knees came up
nearly to my chest but it was above the
rooftops it was a block behind everybody
was beautiful
it was the early evening it was warm
Piazza del Popolo was off to the right
Via del Corso was just in front of us we
had a little table between the two of us
and honored were two plates of room
service spaghetti marinara and a bottle
of Aqua ponic and my phone rang my
American phone now I have been inundated
for months by callers from unrecognized
numbers telling me that I had just been
approved for a bank loan
or for a mortgage I tell them stop
talking take my name off your list and
hang up and then I hang up and I put a
block on their number I picked up my
phone I looked at it I did not recognize
the number
and so gruffly I mean really gruffly I
said hello
and the man's voice on the other end
said Donald it's John Bailey John Bailey
John Bailey is the cinematographer of
ordinary people that was 37 years ago I
said hello John he said Donald I've been
made president to the Academy I said
congratulations
he said no I'm calling to congratulate
you and he explained I asked him if he
would speak with Francine because
Francine had known John and Carol from
before and I passed the phone to her and
she taught for a little bit and then
said goodbye and put the phone down and
we sat there finally she looked at me
and she said we're going to have to lose
weight
[Applause]
I looked at her
I looked at the spaghetti
and I said we'll start tomorrow so we
ate the spaghetti it was cold it was
also the best spaghetti
I have eaten in my entire life
this
this is very important to me to my
family it's like like a door is opened
and a cool wonderfully fresh breath of
air is come in I wish I could say thank
you to all of the characters that I've
played thank them for using their lives
to inform my life I'd love to be able to
thank the multitude of people who are
responsible for me being here they go
Preminger Renata Adler Brian Hutton
Robert Aldrich Christopher Plummer
Federico Fellini Bernardo Bertolucci
Christian Duque John Schlesinger Nicolas
Roeg Fred skip none of us has time for
me to go all the way through that list
this evening but I would like to say
thank you to Ronald Meyer who has been
with me and behind me for as long as I
can remember thank you to dear Josh
Lieberman Jerry Lynn garzo Katherine
Oldham Alan Ross Polly and thank you to
my children my grandchildren our son
rogue called us in Rome a couple of
hours after John had called and he was
weeping that's what this means to our
family he was sobbing so hard it was
incomprehensible and and finally I
understand that he was trying to tell me
that this this was going to look really
wonderful in his office at CAA
even as a young child he had an
impeccable sense of the ridiculous
and of course thank you to Francine
reset from whom from whom everything has
come that's my family from whom
everything has come and to whom
everything is owned I have been a
partner to her for over 45 years and in
all that she has supported me with her
intelligence her intuition her
instruction her her ability to make me
laugh in the diarist of situations her
extraordinary sense of taste her
residual belief in me amongst all of
these her ability to absorb and sustain
the extraordinary ups and downs of this
crazy movie life we have gone through I
mean she deserves a medal for that
so Francine I'm going to get you a medal
and I would like to say thank you to the
governors of the Academy thank you for
putting my name on this it is incredibly
generous of you and I profoundly apprec
for people to give us
it's extraordinary for me I have to tell
you that I have been beset by my mind's
unrelenting interrogation of me
demanding if I deserve this and in that
quandary
I finally found peace in the words of
the great Benjamin Coe bail scheme who
is also known as Jack Benny when he said
as I say to you now I don't deserve this
but I have arthritis and I don't deserve
that either
[Applause]
[Music]